Once upon a time,
in a beautiful wood,
there lived a rabbit named Peter
with a blue jacket..
[ wings flapping]
Peter: Sorry!
.. And no pants.
♪ [Feel it still by Portugal. The Man]♪
Peter: Come one in!  We've got the garden.
Peter: Help yourself to anything.
Peter: Wait, didnt you try to eat me?
Peter: Show me your teeth.
Peter: Do like a-, go like- [growls]
Mr. Tod: [Growls]
Peter: It was you! I knew it! How are you? So good to see you.
♪Ooh woo, I'm a rebel just for kicks now♪
♪I've been feeling it since 1966, now♪
♪Might be over now, but i feel it still♪
Mr.Tod: Commando!!
"Oh yeah, now its a party."
Peter: I can't think of one thing that can possibly stop our fun.
"McGreggor is coming!"
"Everyone hide!"
[Music stops]
McGreggor: [sighs]
McGreggor: Aaaaah!
Pig: Waaaaah!
McGreggor: Aaaaahh!
Pig: [screams in pig]
Both: [scream]
[birds flapping, screaming, footsteps]
[Moooo!]
Peter: This is only the beginning.
Peter: HaHa!
[Brakes screech]
[crickets chirping]
Peter: Phyllis, blink, blink!
Phillips: Headlights.